my name is Michael Printy I'm a
librarian for Western European
humanities and I'd like to welcome you
to the first arts and humanities book
talk of this year in this one is
co-sponsored by the Yale University
Press and by the Macmillan Center and
before I introduce our speakers in our
talk our next talk is on October 29 at
4:30 and that book is City unseen new
visions of an urban planet which is also
a gale press book by Professor Kerin
Sedo and meredith rebound both the Yale
University today's event will be
moderated by William fruit who's an
executive editor at the Yale University
Press and I would like to introduce the
two authors Frances frozen blue and Ian
Shapiro are both professors of political
science here at Yale and the title of
the book is responsible parties saving
democracy from itself and then it's an
ale University Press 2018 so with that
I'd like to turn it over to Bill who
will conduct the rest of the event thank
you thank you I'd like to begin by
thanking the library
sponsoring this discussion especially
Mike printing that stirring library
Maryland will accept the Macmillan
Center and Jennifer door at Yale
University Press will help in organizing
this event the format tonight is this
I'll give a brief introduction that
professors Rosen Jacob Shapiro will each
speak for a few minutes after which
we'll have a conversation about their
new book responsible parties you're
invited to raise your hand and ask a
question at any time after the author's
initial statements are finished but
please observe two rules first we have
limited time so keep your questions
brief second while opinions are welcome
we're following the Alex Trebek rule
please state your answer in the form of
question
Francis Rosen Bluth is the Damon Wells
professor of political science here at
Yale as well as the director of the
program on ethics politics and economics
she was deputy provost for social
sciences and faculty development from
2008 to 2013
her most recent books are forged through
fire a military conflict and the
democratic bargain co-authored with John
Farage on women work in politics
co-authored with torben Iverson and
Japan transformed co-authored with
Michael theis Ian Shapiro is sterling
professor of political science as well
as director of the Macmillan Center he's
taught at Yale since 1984 and was chair
of the political science department from
1999 to 2004 his many books include
pathologies of rational choice theory
co-authored with Donald Green the moral
foundations of politics the real world
of democratic theory the flight from
reality in the human sciences and most
recently politics against another
sorry politics against domination I'm an
editor at Yale University Press and
those of you who have heard my rant know
that I have essentially two criteria for
judging books besides that they be
well-written
first they have to take on some
important question and second they have
to try to change the way we think about
the world Artemus Ward once wrote it
isn't what we don't know that gets us
into trouble it's all the things we know
that ain't so and the question I always
ask my authors is what does everybody
know about your subject that ain't so in
other words how do you want to change
the conventional wisdom about your
subject and why does it matter
often these are things I have to tease
out of a proposal sometimes they aren't
there at all with Francis and Ian's book
the counterintuitive quality is hard to
miss the decentralization of political
power is almost universally seen as a
remedy for the problems of democratic
governments if people are discontented
with slow economic growth income
inequality failed wars or corrupt
and then give them more of a say in
government goes the argument and they'll
give us governments that truly serve the
interests of the people in recent
decades we've tried to increase public
participation through popular
referendums greater use of party
primaries and in some places
proportional representation as a way to
elect honest Outsiders to come in and
drain the swamp we are seeing how well
this is working responsible parties asks
us to consider that perhaps what is
universally put forward as the solution
to democracy's failings is in fact part
of the problem and with that I'd like to
introduce Francis Rosen bluth and Ian
Shapiro
[Applause]
I think I'm miked up oh no it is on yep
well thank you so much bill for that
great introduction and thank you all for
coming to join us in this conversation
we really do want to converse with you
and so we our remarks gonna be very
short but we're gonna try to give you
our argument so that you can perhaps
argue back or improve the way we are
thinking about this so all of us know
and I think we begin with a recognition
that voters are unhappy certainly in the
United States we have a lot to be
unhappy with and there's a whole bunch
of books about the collapse of democracy
and the rise of fascism and where should
we escape from Trump is Stan and on and
on and we agree with all of that but we
have a I guess bill said it best a
slightly contrarian view of what we
should do in response to the problems at
hand so rather than what we call
do-it-yourself politics decentralization
democratization pulling power back from
these nasty elites who've gotten us into
all this trouble we're actually making
an argument in favor of restoring power
to political parties that are able to
enforce to by dint of competition with
one another think about what is good for
most of the people over the long term
political parties are in the business of
establishing a long term reputation for
competence and so instead of referendums
which give voters the ability to pick
apart policies one by one we're
suggesting that we exactly want parties
to bundle issues in such
way that the costs of every policy are
measured against every other policy so
think about proposition 13 how many of
you were even born in 1978 some of you
remember proposition 13 seemed like a
really great idea at the time it was a
popular referendum in California to
reduce taxes what could be better and
voters came out and supported this
proposition to reduce taxes now
unfortunately when you look at one issue
at a time you don't consider the fact
that you have now removed from the state
government a whole bunch of revenue from
the property taxes for schools which
citizens of California also cared about
but that was not on the table at the
time those issues were not bundled and
therefore they got low taxes and poor
schools so political parties are we
argue a central organ maybe the central
organ of democratic accountability
because it is parties that do this work
for us and that must compete against one
another to put forward the best possible
argument that most voters will prefer
and I'm going to turn it over to Ian to
say more especially about particular
examples of when there have been
failures but also how do we do this you
know if we want responsible parties how
actually do we get responsible parties
especially in a country like the United
States that is designed to put barriers
in the way of too much concentration of
power we are not set up for that we have
a president we have two bodies of
Congress that often are controlled by
different parties we have federalism
that reserved rights for States how
would we get parties that are able to
function in this institutional
environment to be able to deliver in the
kind of
that we're talking about so I would
swing it over okay Thank You Francis I
was gratified to see that bill I think
when two colors as needed moderator as
it turned out we had surprisingly easy
time on this book I always liked what
Francis said about two parties and then
a couple of examples things that are
alive I'm aware of the story
I wouldn't start from Pearson
we are very we're very much in this book
trying to make
recommendations which are informed by a
general idea parties but we really want
to start from where we are
so the the main thing about the book is
that it's important to have to agree to
the parties and it's important that the
parties be strong able to manage
themselves internally now you might say
why do it only too many people like PR
we've had lots of parties because we can
have their representative in Parliament
for people to have a representative
everybody can get get their
representation but one of the things
that happens with polish with lots of
parties is you have to form coalition's
and nobody in the coalition ahead of
time so another way of thinking about
this is that two two-party systems are
parties and more like marriages casually
that divorces but basically that put
who knows the next election what the
next election is going to bring so most
recently I know America put together a
coalition with the Free Democrats and
the Greens in Germany couldn't do it and
so went back to a grand coalition with
SPD or in Greece in the last election we
got a coalition with the far left and
the far right who knows what's going to
be happening next time and so this is an
illustrator why you need parties that
can build a brand and campaign into the
future and as Francis was saying have a
reputation for competence at
implementing their agenda just in that
one more analogy is in industrial
negotiations sometimes when they can't
agree they go to arbitration they bring
in an arbitrator and the arbitrator
listens to both sides does some
fact-finding and usually picks some
compromise solution but there's another
kind of arbitration which is called lost
best offer arbitration where both sides
have to make their last best offer and
the arbitrator has to pick one and that
the effect of that is to force the
parties to not be unreasonable not to
take positions for strategic reasons to
compromise on later because if if you
make an extreme if you do you know if
you take an extreme position the the
arbitrator is much more likely to go for
the other side well when you have two
and only two parties you get
winner-take-all politics and loser lose
all politics and so the parties have a
strong interest in creating platforms
that are more like lost best offer
arbitration and
less like regular arbitration where
people have much more much stronger
incentive to misrepresent their position
so as to be able to negotiate later
because in two-party competition you
know that any voters you leave on the
table the other side is likely to get
and those last marginal voters that you
leave on the table might be the
difference between winning everything
and losing everything and this
illustrates the the other point Francis
was making that you want parties that
have an incentive to put together a
broad program that makes it possible to
get all not just your core supporters
but as many of those people that you
might otherwise leave on the table that
might be the difference between defeat
and victory so that's the sense in which
why two big parties or at least
pre-election coalitions of parties are
better than multiple parties now let me
talk a little bit about strong parties
the idea of a strong party is is
reaching for metaphors a party that
operates basically like a team a party
that is where everybody's pulling in the
same direction and trying to get to the
same destination and that can only be
done if everybody is working towards the
same goal now parties exist in very
diverse countries and if you're going to
have two parties you're going to they're
going to come from single-member
district systems like we have in the US
and in the UK but the parties in the
u.s. are much weaker because there's
there's many factors in the u.s. that
interrupt this idea of functioning as a
team one most obvious candidate is
primaries primaries essentially take the
power away from the party leadership
determining who is going to represent
constituencies and what you see in
primaries is extremely low turnout low
turnout sometimes in in the teens in
even the low teens sometimes and the
people who tend to turnout often are on
the extremes of the parties and so for
instance in the last presidential
election those lot the last dozen to 15
primaries that Donald Trump won in the
Republican Party had turned out of
eleven twelve thirteen percent sometimes
less the net effect of this was that
five percent of the u.s. electorate
actually selected Donald Trump and the
Republican Party could have stopped him
from being the candidate in in
congressional races we've had primaries
for half us for more than a century now
and it has the same effect in that what
you have to do to satisfy your primary
voters is not the same thing as what you
have to do to put together a strong
governing coalition precisely because
the primary voters tend to come from the
fringes of the parties and so even
though primaries were introduced by the
progressives in response to a very
corrupt era as a way of reasserting
popular control on politics actually
they have the opposite effect because
you we talk about gridlock or the
inability of leadership's to put
together programs that that they can
actually govern with primaries reinforce
that I'll just mention one other example
and
we should open it up I think I said that
Britain has much stronger and more
disciplined parties than we do and that
has historically has certainly been true
but they have by no means being immune
so one of the things that's happened in
Britain for example in the last 15 years
or so is they move from the
parliamentary party selecting the
leadership to direct election of the
party leaders by the members of the
party who again are the grassroots and
often well to the left in the labour
party of the Labour Party median voter
and to the right in the Conservative
Party of the Conservative Party's median
voter and so you can get the sort of
anomaly we saw in 2016 where the
parliamentary Labour Party had a vote of
no confidence in Jeremy Corbyn by a
hundred and seventy two to forty and
three months later the membership of the
Labour Party re-elected Jeremy Corbyn by
a margin of by 62 percent of the vote
now you imagine Corbin trying to govern
with the parliamentary Labour Party when
he with everything he stands for are
things on which they cannot run and win
in their districts so this is greatly
undermined the capacity of the Labour
Party to actually govern if it stumbles
into office which which it might do so
the the the British are are not immune
from this either and we we talk a lot in
in the US about how presidential ISM
undermines the strength of parties in
the in Congress and that's true
precisely because the president has a
different mandate offered from
congressional members of his or her own
party his until now maybe one day hers
we hope and I'll just close with this
thought it wasn't always that way and it
doesn't have to be that way
in 1808 James Monroe challenged James
Madison for the nomination of the
Democratic Republicans as they were then
called and the way it was resolved was
to create what was called a
Congressional Caucus which was
essentially the the like having the
parliamentary party select its leader
and that was it was basically the
members of Congress that selected them
who would the presidential candidate was
going to be and that system remained in
place until 1828 and that that's from
the point of view of a reform would make
much more sense than what's being called
for by many places because by banning
people because it would make the it
would make the parties more like
parliamentary parties if the leadership
in Congress was selecting the
presidential candidates why'd I stop
there and you all can further questions
[Music]
I have a question can we generalize from
the brexit experience how does the
weakness of parties relate to
well brexit certainly is a good example
of what happens when there is this
desire to handle the issue ourselves
that is voters not trusting parties to
manage this we will do this in a popular
referendum had the British Parliament
voted we all know that brexit would not
have been voted up in the British
Parliament so that's an example of
do-it-yourself politics gone wrong in
other parts of the world are you
thinking about Viktor Orban and
Erewhon do you have anything in mind
particularly and well you mentioned the
German okay yes three elections while so
the German case that Ian just mentioned
was the result of great frustration by
the Social Democrats in entering another
coalition with Angela Merkel cdu/csu
Conservative Union and in response the
Social Democrats put lots of
restrictions on their ministers in
negotiating with Merkel which makes it
even harder to come up with a compromise
and you know this has happened in
Belgium and Netherlands and recently in
Japan there's also been change of rules
of selection of the president of the
Liberal Democratic Party restoring
democracy and the party by giving
members the ability to choose their
leader but what happens then is that it
puts a lot of power in the hands of
local mobilizers in the case of Japan
it's overwhelmingly the rural people who
have a strong interest in blocking let's
say move towards free trade and so it's
going to hamper Bob in this next
administration in negotiating with
foreign countries let me add one point
of my president
Frances just said the thing that people
don't know about brexit is that britain
had never had a referendum until 1965
and the first referendum was called by
Harold Wilson the Labour Prime Minister
on the issue of Europe and he did it in
order to avoid managing conflict within
the Labour Party in order to avoid doing
the hard work of discounting everything
by everything else and forcing those
kind of compromises within the party he
thought now I can punt on this call a
referendum and it lets me off the hook
but the British voters voted 2 to 1 in
favor of Europe at that time and and
Wilson said great this has taken it off
the table forever but of course it did
it because for the reason Francis gave
when people can vote piecemeal on issues
without discounting them by the the cost
for every other issue they make
unrealistic decisions it's sort of like
a small child just eating as much candy
as they want without thinking about the
stomachache and the doctor and so on
later so it's actually started on Europe
as a way of avoiding exactly the kind of
conflict it's produced on Germany I
would just say that the the the the
decentralizing ethos hasn't left them
alone either part of the reason the SPD
has immobilized Merkel's government is
that they too have gone to this direct
election of leadership and the 450,000
members actually had to approve the
coalition agreement that that the SPD
made with miracle and so by the end of
it she had given six ministries to the
SPD including the finance ministry just
to give three ministries to the CSU and
they have very right-wing views about
refugees and immigration she's left with
five ministries not including the
finance ministry if you want it you
think we have you think we have gridlock
if she you know we have time to go into
the chapter in verse of it now but she's
finding it almost impossible to govern
there's cliff eyeing off the cliff I
know where the coalition threatens to
fall apart and it's again because of
this decentralization Germany used to
have stronger parties but there too and
now being weakened by this this call for
more democracy
so in essence she has to assemble a new
coalition on every issue and she has to
live with the possibility that one of
that that the coalition partners will
will bulk this the CSU OMA which is
basic almost the same party was
threatening to bring down a government
over the refugee policy and and the SPD
was recently threatened to do it over
the appointment of a minister so she's
sort of you know being held in equipoise
by the need to maintain this coalition
you have to yell at us
there's
well that's exactly what we're talking
about
it's a democratizing reform with
unintended consequences by immobilizing
the super-delegates we're throwing the
decision to the more extreme positions
making it harder to choose a candidate
who will win right mark that's exactly
that's exactly right that's the origin
and we're some sympathetic substantively
with many of the the concerns that our
point is that beware what you wish for
because you may get something very
different which is a candidate who can't
win so I just supplement that a little
bit what I would say about
super-delegates is that they they're a
really bad bandaid on on a big problem
so you know the the super-delegates were
a response to the fact that the reforms
of night after 1968 which after should
the Chicago Convention and all of that
democratized the control of the party
which produced McGovern who lost 49
states which produce you know Kennedy's
insurgency against Jimmy Carter which
damaged him you know perhaps was the
difference between winning and losing in
1980 we'll never know but then that
producer reaction those sorts of
developments but but the real the real
problem is the decentralized can control
in the first place as I say it would be
much better if the presidential
candidates were selected by the
congressional parties
and the super-delegates of ca1 it
wouldn't happen now but there are other
things one could do for example we will
never get rid of primaries they've been
there for a century in Congress and for
decades in the presidential system off
consequence but one could imagine a
reform way where it was now that in the
event that the that primary turnout is
not say seventy five percent of the
general election turnout in the previous
election then they'll beat this counter
and some other body within the party
whether it's super-delegates or the
congressional leadership or somebody
else because most people don't realize
that primary turnout is so low so if you
set some requirement at that general
sort it would turn up the spotlight for
instance the the the primary in New York
that's got gotten so much attention once
the 12th 14th district 12th district
which produced a candidate self-styled
socialist the the primary that turnout
in that primary was eleven point nine
percent you know so it's not you know
she might survive anyway because it's a
heavily heavily heavily Democratic
district but as soon as she does survive
you've got to think about a
congressional Democratic leadership that
has you know representatives from Ohio
and Indiana and you know California
trying to put together a government
that's going to be a team with people
that far to the left so everybody you
know cheers the the kumbaya moment when
she gets elected in the primary but what
they're missing
is this is contributing to the
fragmentation within within the parties
that makes it impossible for them to
govern which then makes people scream
about the
the dysfunction in Washington and demand
even more if I could just say one other
thing that's related to what we can do
this is a moment in which everybody
understands the problem of gerrymandered
districts they're uncompetitive and
while the attention is on that it would
be good to notice that parties do much
better when districts are heterogeneous
so that those people elected from the
district look more like each other that
is rather than have very geographically
and identity wise distinct districts to
have large heterogeneous districts that
look like the national median voter that
is a situation in which you're much more
likely to get strong parties because
they're going to cohere around a set of
principles that they can all see need to
go forward in your american interest
piece you use the phrase too much
democracy in the wrong places which you
compare to to bloodletting as a folk
remedy that ultimately kills the patient
George Washington killed George
Washington yes
also nikolai gogol but that's beside the
point and and described this as a
bottom-up decision-making is there a
distinction because it may be the
objection to you note in your argument
will be well no that's democracy people
have to to speak is there a distinction
between that sort of bottom of
decision-making and structures that
actually reflective people we're saying
that parties are the way to hold
government accountable to things that
are good for lots of people over the
long run
rather than falling prey to very
powerfully mobilized smaller groups that
then bargain with one another and then
what you get is a pastiche but then the
the resemblance to the people becomes
very attenuated through that process how
do they come up with it yeah so we're
really talking about legislative parties
which is why in a presidential system
it's hard because you got two heads to
the you know actually many heads to this
Hydra which is why the American system
is challenging but in 1950 the American
Political Science Association had a
committee to think about this very
problem and they called their report
return to responsible parties John I
don't know if you John Donna Touch came
up with our title and I don't know if
you knew that you were quoting he shot
Snyder who was a you know professor of
American politics at that time and they
recommended that there be stronger
coordination among the legislative party
and the executive so that they're not
pulling against each other but they're
pulling as Ian says as part of a team
and it's a hard thing to do in our
system parliamentary systems really are
set up better to do that but there there
could be even within the American
constitutional framework ways to improve
on that let me just add something to
that
point which is if you think about the
logic of parliamentary system it's not
that we're going to create one but what
we want to try and approximate the the
backbenches delegate a lot of authority
to the front branches to come up with
the platform that you're talking about
because they know that the front
branches are looking across all the
constituencies and trying to make sure
as I said earlier that they don't leave
any more votes on the table that they
have to because it's the difference
between winning everything and losing
everything so so the back benches had
have an interest in delegating that
authority to fund branches but only on
condition that they deliver so they give
them enough rope to hang themselves
right you wouldn't get a situation in a
parliamentary system were like Nancy
Pelosi has led that the Democrats to
four successive defeats and she's still
there that couldn't happen in a day the
back ranches would have no reason to
keep giving authority to somebody who
couldn't deliver victory because that
that's what the that's the one thing
they have to get now she's not held
accountable because responsibilities
defused people bring the president
things are different in off-year
elections all kinds of insurance money
she raises money and they need money
issues the best fundraiser of all time
people say so she's she's protected even
though she's an ineffective leader and
that's why we that's what we mean by by
weak partners so really you know coming
up with reforms that militate against
that feature of the system is what we're
looking for
this gentleman blacks we're going
elevated people
[Music]
[Music]
well it's not new you know
the progressives had a whole raft of
popularizing reforms because of corrupt
machine politics so anything can prompt
this blaming of parties and we're just
sounding the alarm against a simplistic
view of parties that doesn't take into
account the problem of weak parties we
need stronger parties that can solve
problems not weaker ones that will cede
accountability another way of putting it
is life's about trade-offs there's no
perfect solution to anything and there's
actually a trade-off between popular
participation and accountable government
and where we're putting a thumb on the
scale for
government we want to move towards a
world in which the politicians that get
elected are actually how accountable for
the policies that they were elected to
implement and a lot of participation and
all levels essentially immobilizes them
and makes that and militates could I
just say one of the thing max because
you know we really admire European
success in the post-war period Europe
was far better at the United than the
United States at redistributing income
and having a decent economy while also
having elements of of welfare and
inequality and what we are observing now
is a fragmentation on the left
disproportionately because of the
decline of industrial jobs and the
unions that were in lockstep with Social
Democratic parties and as that happens
as the left fragments we are seeing in
Europe the same kind of immobilize 'im
that comes with a system like the
American one where you have checks and
balances so Europe is not immune to this
problem of fragmented political
authority so Europe needs to figure out
how they're going to deal with this
problem in Sweden the right the parties
on the right have been very successful
in forming a coalition of parties and in
fact they've just thrown out laufen the
Prime Minister of the Social Democrats
so there is a way for parties to form
pre-election coalition's to help them
function more like a team that can be
accountable but they they're going to
have to do something like that
proportional representation is a whole
set of challenges of its own
little parties to war like teens and
spend
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes well part of the reason money is
such a big deal in American politics is
exactly because parties are weak so a
member of a party can't campaign on the
basis of a platform
what is the platform they're running
against one another in the same party so
they need to cultivate individual
support countries that have strong
parties have far less money floating
around in campaign processes can the
parties discipline themselves no but
voters can punish and reward really more
by setting up incentive structures for
example you know districting in such a
way as to force them to reach a wider
audience or as in was saying make these
primaries really more about the average
voter and not extreme voters what else
would you
so there has been a move in a number of
states away from having the state
legislatures do the districting on every
ten years after the census which you
know whoever's put whichever part is
controlling the state legislature then
has the incentive to chime gerrymander
to their own advantage but if you look
at at the most of the states that have
gone to so-called independent
commissions most of them are actually
bipartisan commissions they're not
independent commissions and they're not
they're not civil servants or technical
astir at their commitment so many
Democrats I'm a Republican and the
danger with that is that they'll
gerrymander to carve up the state
partisan gerrymandering so-called which
the Supreme Court has you said well in
principle yes we would be willing to
strike down partisan gerrymandering if
it gets too extreme but they've never
actually done it and they haven't they
haven't taken the axe to agreements
among parties to divide up States and of
course if you do that to get States full
of safe seats where all the elections
are really the intra-party competitions
in the primary so what you really need
is not bipartisan commissions but
nonpartisan commissions well the system
in the UK which is I think good on this
front is the independent commission does
the redistricting and then Parliament
can vote it up or down but they can't
change it you need some mechanism of
that sort and and the mandate to the
district is should be to draw districts
that are going to be competitive between
parties because that's what you really
want a gerrymander for inter party
competition our bumper stickers
competition between parties is good
competition within parties is bad
if you talk louder
[Music]
well the intra-party so i don't know if
everybody heard that but some countries
that have proportional representation
which is an electoral system where the
parties get the number of seats
proportional to the votes they get but
the voter only sees a list and so this
conduces to strong parties the party
selects the list but in some countries
voters have the opportunity to tick
names of people they want from any place
on the list and this sounds great in
principle but it's exactly the kind of
democratizing reform we think weakens
parties it makes it a lot harder for the
party to say no we're not talking about
individuals here we're talking about
these ideas that we all agree to and the
people on this list all are pulling in
that same direction when you have the
opportunity to rise up the list you know
maybe even from below the point where
you wouldn't get elected you have an
incentive to do something a little
different go to voters and say the party
is good I agree with the party but I
will also do these other things so we we
appreciate the fact that in Sweden for
example they are still trying very hard
not to go that path despite the fact
that there is a lot of pressure there's
always pressure on parties to open up
the list in that way and we think it's
better for them not to you also mention
referendums
okay go ahead
well so Switzerland you know is this
remarkably functional place despite
rules that we don't think should work
very well so that's why we're saying you
you do it you do it we haven't quite
figured that one out I would say there
was a show on you probably know this
it's a famous article by yens Hine
Muller on a referendum that was very a
anti-immigrant and so that's the problem
with referendums and kind of populist
seeding of territory you know policy
territory you get these emotional yahoo
kinds of responses from the voters and
in this case in this particular case the
Constitutional Court I believe it was in
my right John yeah
overruled the results of that referendum
on behalf of the interests of the whole
country because they actually need those
immigrants you know Switzerland needs
and has benefited enormous Lee from a
diversity of populations so just to say
that both of those institutions are
dangerous the nice I would just add a
couple of points about Switzerland it
has it is not you know it is the system
in which first of all is pretty small
country and I think that that how
scalable it is is a real question you
know it saying hey it's not just the
anti-immigrant stuff but this is a
country that managed to avoid giving
women the
until 1973 one so you know there's a
downside to empowering intense troops
what
[Music]
so I'd say two things about this we are
here focusing on what difference do the
rules governing the organization
operation of parties in elections
what world that plays we're not saying
it's the whole story and clearly you
know they're two enormous facts that are
governing political economy and politics
in more countries over the last 35 40
years one is the worldwide collapse of
communism and the other is the collapse
of organized labor and the left and so
that that is playing at those two things
are playing themselves out in all
political systems and you can see this
by comparing Britain with Europe Britain
in the u.s. with Europe in Britain in
the u.s. the collapse of the union
movement eventually forced the sort of
new labour and the new Democrats and the
the kind of love affair with Wall Street
and all that in these parties which then
alienated some of the people you're
talking about and in Europe as Frances
it said we've seen this now this
fragmentation of the left into multiple
parties not just the greens but you know
left old Social Democrats and then the
far left and some are flipping over to
the sort of AFD on the far right so all
of these systems are coping with
with the absence of a serious socialist
alternative because of the disappearance
of communism and the concomitant
collapse of the left and of trade
supported by a union movement that is is
playing itself out differently in
different ways so what you know you
could say well these are the giant
forces shaping everything and what we're
talking about is to some degree on the
margin I think there's some truth to
that but it's still not a trivial margin
it's what I would say and you have to
work at that work in the areas you can
work and we're just saying first of all
don't make it even worse and then think
about things that might push in the
other direction then what you would add
to that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well you said two separate things the
first thing you said was the parties are
internally coherent only if you look at
roll call votes on things that they know
are not going to pass they're actually
internally very incoherent and so how do
we strengthen parties that is a very
hard question but we think that if
voters appreciate the problem they're
more likely to put pressure and put out
of office
the politicians associated with refusing
to budge on that so that has to come
from a better informed electorate could
I just add one thing to that the parties
look more coherent than they are as
Francis said partly because of roll call
votes and partly because they they
campaign
ideologically distinct platforms than
they used to do but the Blanco
scientists at the University of Maryland
Francis Lee has done the best work on
this if you look at what parties
actually enact the they're no more able
to enact partisan agendas than they were
in the 1970s on virtually all
legislation including major legislation
they have to get the support of at least
at least one of the the other part in at
least one of the houses and so something
that the tax cut is actually a big very
little legislation passes in that play
Obamacare is a big outlier and usually
when we have a whole chapter about
Obamacare because when you look at the
rents that were extracted by interest
groups to get Obamacare through Congress
they're enormous from the
pharmaceuticals from the insurance
companies from all these various other
groups that all got their pound of flesh
out of the belt as a condition for
passage very unlike the NHS that was
passed in Britain in in 1947 so that the
more typical case is that the rich say
the Republicans could quote 67 times a
lot of it was to repeal Obamacare when
they knew Obama would veto would
wouldn't get through the Senate or
whatever was just position taking but
when it actually came to repeating that
they couldn't do it and so that's the
much more typical case despite all the
wind and fear fury of partisanship most
actual
as bipartisan as it ever lost which this
system pretty much forces we're out of
time but we're happy to chat afterwards
up here and some of you oh you do the
strength of parties you know one one
quickly measure of this is simply the
fact that the word primary is now alert
when when look you know who the
individual representatives and Senators
are answerable to it's not the party
leadership anymore they're terrified of
being primary and that's really what
determines they're both much more than
what the leaders said and that to me is
an indication that the church strength
of parties in ideological coherence and
and the vast amounts of money that have
really doesn't translate into effective
governance my question has to do with
with minorities how are powerful parties
in answer to protecting vulnerable
minorities and why is working within a
party a better strategy than forming a
third party so this is a very great
concern and our argument is that in the
current system minorities are pretty
much ignored because their vote can be
counted on and to have diverse districts
in which both parties have to go after
everybody would improve the lot in terms
of policy outcomes of minorities over
the system that we have now about
minorities obviously
you should go to a good bookstore named
after about minorities but you know
again we've gone in the wrong direction
because majority minority districts get
better so-called descriptive
representation when when already into
Congress and that's happened since the
1970s but look at the legislative games
what major legislation helping minority
interest has passed since the Civil
Rights Act the Voting Rights Act
nothing so you know what you look at the
output side of the equation and ask
yourself how is this really serving the
interests of minorities and as for that
the cost of majority minority districts
as I said reach out to three
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]